Again i'm talking to mr. Jay lloyd
who worked for dorman long and co.
In middlesbrough during the construction
of the sydney harbour bridge. Do you
member that time do you most like. It was
yesterday. What did you do. Did you work
in the workshop there was
a drill and what did you what parts
you drill the potus is all about.
On the bridge with the lewis had machine.
Drilled everything. So many fifth all was
said that i don't go. But this is where
the five six players together. And
they were brought out already drilled on
a digital yes but what else was made in
dorman like all the sections of the flat
work. I worked on the. On the foundations
of drill the uncles for the foundation.
Like plimsoll managed by the
completed the bearings.
And they were all set. It set mangle every
all up to be perfect and where did the
steel come from prompt things. At middlesbrough
will be yes. And do you remember
where while you were drilling there with
the accuracy you had to work. You had to
be everything you thought up to be
dead. And you said lou said jill
a machine and were there with it any more
accurate than any other job he worked on
you know it had to be perfect. He wasn't
perfect. It was no good. It was only
a very small proportion of the
stuff that the steel that was
a was worked in dorman long. Was it was
done in middlesborough wasn't it or not
there's thousands of tons of it. I would
realize that that. Nearly seventy over
seventy per cent of the steel came with
a what i mean is. Was working drilling and
such like there wasn't an awful lot of
that nearly all got in the bridge out it
middle. But most it came out here straight
as plates didn't it as plates yes but say
we've all been drilled marked already for
this embryonic idea. What else what
other parts. Did you work on that we
started on the foundations first. And
we went on the flat where all the heavy
plates that could be plants was that could
be drilled before he could bridge well
before he's got
a champ let on the top and the places that
you do. All right. But you have to be
set to be set every fifty or was five or
like to get what you want. And i think you
said perfect. And how long we
are working for dorman like
1929. Tonight he said he's thirty three. I
mean what happened here. Not an accident
. Could you tell us about that to me i
was off work. Just over eleven months
and i could you get back on
work and i found we had job as
a laborer and. It was three months
you just said. You can't you finish
to get any compensation or anything
like. All i do i was up with
a third i mean where does
that was that in the fort was
a week. And how long for that. I
was up eleven months eleven months
for me. And when they laid you off after
that nothing just just said to settle me
want their cards finished what happened.
You then went on the means test on the
door and did you get
a doll. Yes got the door. What sort of
what was that all in england in those days
shows that week that issues and week was
how high compared to here and here and on
the means test. I got six times
a week. Actually if i was work and i
was drawn thirty eight children. I was
a week better off work and what i was on
the dole and paid the rent. A lot of money
and there was this. Here they had coupons
that you have coupons there. Yes you got
some money as well as coupons. So you got
you do all yes. Well here in new south
wales they didn't get any they got very
very little money if anything it was all
coupons you had nothing to pay the rent
with. That was we were actors was telling.
I worked two years full time we had i
might five it natal quite of us six and
that's mine. How much you get paid for
that. It worked out about ten percent no.
When i worked the five nights that was
eighty four what i was and what were their
working conditions like in the shops there.
The collet the chinese lab. Most of it
was outside where you can see. Was there
any sort of fairly where to put your
clothes or whatever to wash. No nothing.
And there was no lunchroom or anything
like oh no just sit down from the emission
toilet while you work and. You can see
what to do over long is like when they got
here. It was the worst thing. I think
over going to be like we're starting
a dominant personally moment
a lot of people. It was that was
a lively ah but was the worst thing ever
done. And how like how long. Actually we
working on the bridge work
three years three years it's
a lot of steel. How many of you were there
working on on the bridge steelworks
would be an 800 in the bridge. But all
working on the sydney harbour bridge
was an island it was
a bridge. But in the man is
it was would be what 800 men
. And yet many of the people here who
worked in the workshops in australia they
reckon that they did it all as far as the
processing of the steel. Did you know the
bridge up as it what had and you steel plant
next to one another one of the men had
come out the men that went
back went back as manager. And
he brought that. Great buck is
a bridge yard manager they come from the
martins worked on the bridge the woman is
just oh dear oh yes i know henry and alfred
martin both or both worked here. Henry
martin was a manager in the shops
here. He was a publication. He was
a tablet maker and he's using yes and he
can back it but as you know the bridge had
it all to block the he was the diplomat
of the. General manager of diamond works
. Do you remember them before the they
came out here to you didn't but my father
did. What work in class people
with the martin. But they were
hard nonetheless. And he was a
hard man to work for and he was
a bad mother worked for my pals
as a diplomat and he was like mr.
Hauck. There was
a little drink with them. What was how
long we are out of work during the
depression after you finished up
a terminal. 1930 to kill people. Yes
that's
a long time to start back on the docks
and do you make out reasonably then the
docks. If you're going to the jungle welfare
was well it was just i mean pens. All
in pens maybe fifty amount fight but you
know. If they have days were quite of
a day's work. That's like what they
call toeing the line here twice
a day. That's right. So it was the same.
Five times they did middle six o'clock
eight o'clock different was started different
times you go through afterward. Every
two hours six o'clock at night so we
need to get in permanent work again.
thirty six. I've got
a card on the devastating.
1936. That sounds hard
. Anything else stands out in your mind.
Well you while you were working in the
shop there for tom and sam so you may
think that once that i didn't have it. I
don't need to because they gave a
bad. Thank you thank you. Us alone.